Adam how do you know this is what you're
meant to do filmmaking you know this is
for you that I think that's a tough
question but I also think I know how I
can answer that it's it's the feeling
that I get when I do it first and
foremost that it really makes me feel
most like myself you know in other stuff
other jobs in other situations in life I
definitely sometimes feel like I'm not
myself you know or it can't be myself
I'm not my most authentic self
I think someone very smart put it but
but filmmaking that's where that's where
I really feel that and I love it you
know it's it's the sort of thing where
in life if you can choose the pain
you're given then that's better than
having pain forced upon you and the fact
that filmmaking has all of these highs
and lows and it can be exhilarating and
it can be super painful you know when
you get rejected or when a project
doesn't come together or a project that
you've put out isn't received how you
might want it to be received like the
fact that those are the pain points that
I can shoes is is kind of great because
it's all part of it you know like you
can't have those sort of dizzying highs
of like a film plane and a theatre or a
huge crowd at Fantasia loving no
touching like those are things I'm gonna
remember forever
you know but with that comes the movie
that comes out and no one cares about or
those multiple multiple rejections from
film festivals that you think your film
is like a sure thing and you get
rejected and you never know why you know
it's just you get the sorry thanks for
submitting and that is crushing you know
the nun not knowing like where other
films better was it just the you know
the Film Festival's taste like you never
know but telling stories and being able
to impact people and make them think and
make them feel like if you can make an
audience feel like that is an amazing
almost addicting feeling you know making
an audience laughs or cringe or shed a
tear which I I'm hopeful my latest short
can do and a few friends who have seen
it it's it's not quite released yet but
they've said that it has done that and
that is just sort of an honor and an
amazing feeling to be able to connect
with people and I think that's really
what it's all about
is that through my work and through the
stories that I want to tell I'm
connecting with people you know like I
may go to a party or a place to where I
feel uncomfortable and it's kind of hard
to talk to people right but with
filmmaking like it's that same sort of
connection and it's easier to talk to
people in some ways you know through
storytelling that's that's interesting
too yeah I know especially for people
that myself included sometimes if I'm in
a big group I freeze up and I'm just not
but if it's about a film or a story an
author it's different cuz it's a shared
experience yeah and so there's just a
comfortable realm you can enter with
that mm-hmm
with with a film that you spend so much
time with whether it's a short or a
feature and then at some point I would
imagine there's almost like a letting go
period where you're like okay it's out
there
it's been received for better or worse
and now it's time for me to move on to
something new can you talk about that
process of where you where you come to
that point where you know it's time to
now start something new
totally yeah yeah and the latest example
is that of that is my future film broken
ceiling so that was the one that was
shot in four days but the one that I
needed to get done before you know I
2:31 that you know after sort of a year
of like tinkering and sending it to
festivals and getting feedback from
people and like doing a little bit of
reality and it finally found a
distributor which was great and it was
put up on you know Amazon and iTunes and
to be TV and you know in February 2018
it came out and there was that big sort
of like oh this is amazing like it's out
there and you hit the social media
really hard and you know we were able to
get a review from the LA Times that was
pretty complimentary great and then we
got a review from The Hollywood Reporter
which completely destroyed us but I made
it a point to send emails to both the
writers and thank them for that why you
know because they spent an hour and a
half of their time to review a super low
budget movie that was shot in four days
you know these are the film credits for
the LA Times and The Hollywood Reporter
like I had to thank them for that
because you know back in the day I would
never imagine having my movie you know
having a picture of it and a review of
it turn up in the hard copy of the LA
Times you know that I can go down to the
corner Starbucks and I did I literally
did this as soon as it came out my
distributor was like hey you're in the
LA Times printed edition I was like oh
my god I need these printed editions
where does one buy a newspaper nowadays
I don't know if these exists anymore
so I went to a couple places the liquor
store didn't have it I was like okay
cool
went to the Starbucks god bless him they
had them so I was like I need to buy all
of your copies and I did I bought all
six of them we've got some weird looks
but it's like I don't care I need let's
prove I got to have that moment that you
hear about that like you know the review
comes out in the trades and they go and
they buy it from the newsstand I got to
have that which was super cool so all of
that was very exciting and you know
getting people to watch it when it first
came out it was great and you know you
push and push and you you know you get
people to watch and they start reviewing
it on Amazon and like that's exciting
and you get to see what people think of
it as well and then you're doing the
outreach because you
wanna get some Rotten Tomatoes scores so
you're reaching out and like pinging so
many reviewers who you know we don't
necessarily have the time to review it
so you're getting reviews here and there
and that helps and that's great and
that's exciting
and then you know it sort of starts to
taper off like a few months in it starts
to slow down and then you start to think
well what can I do to keep it going you
know cuz you really want it to keep
going because there's so many people
that can still watch it there's there's
so many different audience members you
know all around the globe everywhere you
know and so you're like how do I reach
them how do I reach them you know what's
the best way to do that and that can be
successful or that can be not successful
myself I hired a social media firm to
sort of run the Instagram account
because social media is something that
I'm not at all talented in and I don't
have that much interest in I know it's
something that you have to do but it is
very very hard to cut through the noise
because everybody is posting everything
at all hours minutes seconds of the day
that trying to find your fans and keep
them engaged is fairly exhausting and
but can be ultimately rewarding and and
it was and there were definitely some
successes but I found that I needed to
start letting it go because you know
you're not
if you can't really expand the you know
the people that are on your Instagram
you know the followers for example is
hard you're just kind of screaming the
same message at them over and over and
you're not keeping them anything new so
you have to try to keep them engaged
with other things it may not be movie
focused you know like if your movie you
know has some social commentary then you
can pull up stuff from the news and talk
about that like there's a lot of ways to
keep social media interesting instead of
like always being like watch my movie
because people are going to turn that
off pretty quick but ya did that for six
months solid and that's
decent results I can't say that there
were amazing results you know but you
know it worked it worked for the most
part but after that I realized that I
had to let it go a little bit you know
like I couldn't keep pushing that I
would try to get reviews where I could
but that big push was sort of over and I
needed to to let it go and and work on
something new you know because I think
for me the worst thing that I could have
done like is is to keep pushing that
like if I had sitting here today was
still pushing broken ceiling super super
hard and not working on anything new and
not trying to do that then that would be
a big mistake
I think because you know it felt natural
at the point you know it was about maybe
about yeah about a year in that it had
been on you know Amazon had to be TV and
all those I was like okay like I gotta
push something else and and you got to
keep working on stuff of course like and
through that time I was definitely
working on so many things in addition to
you know trying to push the film and
that's why I had to hire that social
media firm because I knew that I needed
to be creating new stuff like I knew
that I needed to do a new short you know
another feature I would have loved to do
but the funding aspect is is quite
difficult to do but I knew that I could
you know self fund another small short
do that work on something else just keep
that going because the big thing was
getting on set again because in 2015 was
a heck of a year because we shot no
touching no we shot we shot broken
ceiling first in June so I shot the
feature broken ceiling before we shot no
touching which was done in the fall but
imagine being able to shoot a feature
and a short in the same year like that's
kind of a dream but then I didn't step
behind the camera until February of this
year of 2019 you know so that's three
four years of not directing and I found
that very hard you know I was writing a
lot but I wasn't behind the camera you
know because it's hard to squeeze in
time to do that when you're trying to
put out a feature and get people
interested in that and then writing
other projects you know so yeah it was
good to get behind the camera again
you